so i'm doing this like airline food diet
it's like all i eat and i've lost like
16 pounds oh my god amy i almost forgot
to tell you
we got a new receptionist at work ew no
way yeah so i'm in the common area alone
many of my own business yeah oh she said
something to you she came up to me
and no joke she's like hi i'm sandy i
don't believe we've met yet oh
she said that to you no amy i'm not even
kidding you
she's crazy um yeah no like i'm scared
like crazy
like get this [ __ ] away from me she's
psychopathically bat [ __ ] crazy oh my
god that totally reminds
me i have a new neighbor ew yeah she
comes over my house she knocks on the
door with like a
package under her arm um stalker match
um
yeah and she looks me in the eye and she
says to me um
excuse me i think the postman dropped
this package off at my house by accident
she said that to you
yeah crazy bad i mean like i'm gonna
have to move because this bitch's nut
burgers make looney tunes
stand at the foot of my bed with a knife
crazy oh my god that totally reminds me
oh yeah you remember that girl at
starbucks the crazy one no a different
one she's new i haven't met her yet well
she's crazy
uh-huh she gives me my change and then
she's like thanks
bye she smiled at you like that
how crazy is that that's like that's
like insane in the membrane crazy like
like this is the membrane she's inside
of it because that's insane no like i'm
not even kidding you amy that's crazy
like it puts the lotion in the basket or
else it gets the hose again cray to the
mother
cray yeah like if jay-z had a sister her
name would be cray hey
you ladies want to meet channing tatum
oh
is he really in there serious oh tanning
tanning what are you doing in a van i
think crazy i don't see you channing why
are you hiding
in here shanny are you like in a little
ball
it smells like mildew in here sharp
jagged rusty
is that a meat hut
you